Chaos and panic on the high sea – a constant challenge for the crew of the MV Aquarius.
The vessel – staffed only with volunteers
- has run more than 100 rescue missions i
in the Mediterranean – and saved more than 15,000 migrants.
Hauke Mack, Sea and Rescue Operator MV Aquarius:
“The current situation is disastrous.
More and more people are coming, they're fleeing from Libya and it's very urgent that somebody
takes care of them as soon as possible, otherwise they will just drown and die.”
But the MV Aquarius and other N-G-O operated rescue vessels have recently come under fire.
Several weeks ago, members of the right-wing group Generazione Identitaria blocked the
departure of the rescue ship.
They claim that rescue boats are a pull-factor, attracting migrants and enticing smugglers.
PTC Lars Scholtyssyk: “The proliferation
of charities operating rescue vessels in
the Mediterranean has be come one of the most controversial issue in this years'
migrant crisis here in Italy.
The Italian government is therefore working on a code of conduct for NGOs that might severely
constrain their operations.”
Members of the European Parliament who visited the MV Aquarius last week, are criticizing
this move.
“As if the NGOs were the problem – in this situation.
With what we see in Syria, with what we see in Libya, with what we see in some African
countries where any fundamental right is constantly denied.
I don't think NGOs are the problem.”
But the accusations have had an effect on
public opinion.
Half of all Italians say the don't trust the
rescue charities.
That's not fair, says parliamentarian Theresa
Reintke.
Theresa Reintke, Member of the European Parliament:
“Actually this should not be their responsibility.
These are civilians who have taken responsibility
for something that actually the European states
should have a responsibility for to organize
these search and rescue operations.”
So far this year, charities like the MV Aquarius
have carried out more than a third of all
rescues in the Mediterranean.
While the recent surge in arrivals is once
again testing Italy's patience with the EU,
it seems the country is venting its frustration
on the aid workers.